thank you epic games for sponsoring this
video fortnite's season six primal just
dropped if you haven't already go
download fortnite and in this video
fortnite is gonna assign us a random
teammate and if we win our next game of
fortnite
that random person gets 50 000 in cash
they're gonna have to be really good at
the game
joshie joshie hi if we win this game of
fortnite that we are about to play i
will give you 50
000 in cash oh my gosh okay it starts in
three
two one good luck i just hope you're
ready to carry because
every single other person in this lobby
you shoot at fortnite this is my first
game good luck joshie
i'm gonna try my best oh i jumped too
early but i'll fly there it's all good
wait i hit my space bar on accident do
you just
not want him to have fifty thousand
dollars we need to stick together to win
everyone go to dirty docks no one's
gonna want there because it's musty and
old
all right josh is calling it man the
pressure's on him another team's coming
in hot we better not get squad wiped
landon i'm relying on you right now
landon's on the other side of the map
i'll be there in a second guys you're
all gonna be fine all right i'm landing
in the middle building in the back
i'll land near you so you don't die all
right i got a shotgun
i see a rando no that's a bot oh he's
the bot's killing me oh he boxed him up
leave the bottom there jimmy don't screw
with the bot oh wait you're in there
with the bot
i'm bringing you guys a present oh shoot
get out of the way
are you guys blowing yourself up come on
guys we want joshy to win 50 000
oh there's miranda randall okay we need
to play smart here
easy mate i'm so good at this game let
me just
nice we are cracked yeah here we go okay
joshy what are you going to spend your
money on i'm probably going to buy
some stuff for a new gaming setup why
are you talking like you already won
no wait but he asked me landon doesn't
care if you win 50 grand don't let him
distract you i
care about joshy i've known this man my
whole life i gotta find an upgrade guy
i'm gonna i'm willing to spend all my
fortnite gold
you guys want to get in my car i just
got it today but chandler can you drive
well
i can drive i don't know yeah i don't
know if i want to get in that car
wait we're getting shot at i'll go sort
of me out boys oh i'll go get him okay
attacking for 33
oh there's three of them i'm watching
chandler just have the fight of his life
right now
what are you doing get him chandler get
cracked
get correct good job guys wait don't
kill him right away oh teammate teammate
oh i'm dying there's a llama wait
there's a lava does anyone need anything
from the llama
i'm 30 health joshie here's how much i
care about you
i'm gonna spend all my gold to upgrade
my weapons
just for you oh thank you does anyone
need any um shield because i've got
three big pots and four minis how are
you so calm with this much money on the
line because
you know i'm just here for the
experience have you experienced 50 grand
in your bank account i won't know how
much 50 grand is
until i have it and by the way i will
have it i'm fully confident oh he's got
the confidence i like it
i'm trying to kill this frog i want i
want
i killed a frog landon what are your
thoughts on the new season six well you
know we're just walking it's really cool
man there's chickens i'll go find you a
chicken bastard
we don't need balloons anymore all we
need are chickens yeah all right so
there's 32 people left
chandler just climb this real quick
there's actually no fall damage this
season
oh really that's pretty nice yeah yeah
so if you jump off there you can glide
why aren't you doing it i've got to go
get some more loot
jayla someone's shooting it he's over
there he's there near the couch oh i
just lost half my health
you liar you're supposed to go a little
bit higher up on the on the ramp there
i'm on fire i'm burning ah i just got
shot hey there's a warthog
what are these josh if you win this game
mate you've uh
accomplished something amazing wait we
need to find people we can't just let
josh get 50 grand without killing mini
team let's just like eliminate ourselves
and let joshie go solo mate and see if
he can
actually i like that no i don't like
that idea
linda i think this is too easy can you
just throw grenades on yourself and
respect it absolutely that's fun that's
fine with me
i don't know i'm not very good at this
game
that's what bae said mate no wait no
i'll throw him in the river sing some
sad music or something as i float down
the river all right goodbye laser
see you guys it was really nice to wake
up at 1am to do this
all right josh now let's meet you and
chandler they're shooting in that
direction but we're not going to rush
them for the reason that if we rush them
we'll probably die
nope we should rush them no that is a
horrible idea i need this 50 000
oh there's people you're not very good
at aiming what do you mean i just
knocked that kid
oh i see someone in the distance boom
boom blue
blue oh i'm missing
oh what this has rockets oh my goodness
i'm insane
go fight them bro don't be scared all
right
i knocked one i knocked one oh i'm
popping them
ah wait do you need help sir hello i can
help you
oh i'll bring you to safety yeah this is
so big bye
shayla just cheated him out of the south
if you stand on it it'll heal you
all right cool yeah yeah now it's
healing you right now wait
laser you're not helping let's heal this
person i would like to cook them alive
taylor this has been too easy so far me
and you are not allowed to shoot anymore
okay if you can't shoot then give me the
ammo what so you guys get to not shoot
but i had to die
there's seven people left josh can you
do this i can do this
i think i'll be fine i'm i'm cheering
you on oh
oh josh brown all right pj
josh do you need help yeah but like
don't help me because you're not alone
i can do this hi josh can you wipe this
person i think i'm capable of it
oh josh there's a grenade on your right
on top of you grenades
i killed him i killed him i killed him
joshi has no fear mate your structure is
about to go away
who's throwing them here let me get rid
of these walls so you can see
they just don't want to sweat they just
know you're ready a chicken
jimmy we can get the chickens to follow
us if we press e honestly joshie you
can't get the 50 grand on until you
catch the chicken
okay okay 50 grand is on the line he's
just chasing a chicken
no you got it pretend it's chicken
nuggets josh
yeah let's go all right yes taylor get
yourself a chicken
we gotta follow josh in a battle with
chicken if you build up with that you
can actually fly a very long time
josh somebody's shooting it oh hydra
[ __ ] nah
chandler's dead joshie can you feel the
pressure i can
okay i don't even know where it's coming
from no no no no no no
i'm distracting oh i'm running away help
me
help your teammate kill them yeah revive
me first actually
i'll give you an extra hundred bucks if
you throw him in the storm
dude don't you oh my god no good job
joshie
all right now it's me and you josh i
think i'm capable of this
2d2 but i'm not using a weapon up to
your right to your right
right is uh the zone i really needed to
know that where are they mate they could
literally be anywhere at this point
there's four people left okay oh oh gee
watch out watch out watch out look at
that immediate build
oh he's drained he's crashed he's
cracked oh i knocked him
josh your wall is gone where'd your wall
go last person
bro he's literally free this kill is for
50k
josh why are you missing just hit them
it's not that hard
you just won fifty thousand dollars i
just won fifty thousand dollars
fifty thousand one hundred dollars this
is my mom
miss joshi your son just won fifty
thousand dollars in cash no he did not
he did actually we just won fifty
thousand dollars
joshi and miss joshi what are you gonna
spend the 50 000
cold hard cash on fortnight especially
and going to mr beast restaurant
as you said thank you for watching
goodbye chris has a fortnight nerf gun
just call me john wick